kommen wir jetzt nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt top 14
deutsch als landessprache das ist ein
antrag der fdp fraktion bringt einen
gesetzentwurf ein der vor sie deutsch
als landessprache im grundgesetz
festzuschreiben
staatliches handeln solle künftig darauf
verpflichtet werden die deutsche sprache
zum haupt kommunikationsmedium aller
menschen in deutschland zu machen so
lautet der antrag der afd widerspruch
kann ist es so beschlossen und der erst
erinnert er diesen antrag hier auch
einbringt ist der vorsitzende des
rechtsausschusses stefan brandner von
der afd
das kann allerdings erst tun wenn die
abgeordneten hier sich wieder hingesetzt
haben denn das ist so üblich nach einem
tagesordnungspunkt wechselt ja so ein
bisschen das plenum und
bundestagspräsident schäuble bemängelt
hier zu recht dass es noch zu laut sein
und dann eröffne ich die auswahl und das
wort den kollegen stefan brandner afd
[Applaus]
und morgen meine damen und herren
was gibt es schöneres als im sonnigen
tag vor den vollen bänken der eigenen
fraktionen über ein thema zu sprechen
was nicht nur für feingeister geeignet
ist sondern wo wir uns unterstützung des
gesamten naja die großer
gesellschaftlicher schichten gewiss sein
können und es geht um den artikel 22
absatz 3 des grundgesetzes jedes bislang
nicht gibt wir wollen ihn einfügen mit
dem schlichten satz die landessprache in
der bundesrepublik deutschland ist
deutsch dieser satz soll das grundgesetz
eingefügt werden
damit stehen wir nicht allein das ist
keine ihre idee der af.de sondern wir
stehen quer beet auf einem fundament mit
vielen persönlichkeiten herr steinmeier
bundespräsident möchte eine überflutung
der deutschen sprache mit anglizismen
verhindern
norbert lammert er saß bis vor kurzem
auf dem stuhl hinter mir hat sich
deutlich dazu geäußert dass deutsch ins
grundgesetz aufgenommen werden soll ich
zitiere ihnen aus einer rede am
11.11.2009 17 anlässlich der verleihung
des kulturpreises deutsche sprache in
kassel ich zitiere deutsch ist zunächst
eine von mehreren tausend sprachen die
auf diesem globus gesprochen werden und
insofern nichts besonderes da hat er
recht aber sie ist unsere sprache die
sprache der deutschen eine sprache die
im land seien namen gegeben hat zitat
ende meinen demontieren und erleidet das
begründet schon die aufnahme des
deutschen als landessprache ins
grundgesetz nicht nur solche politischen
schwergewichte wie herr steinmeier und
herr lammert haben sich dafür
ausgesprochen
auch schwergewichte wie monika grütters
beauftragte der bundesregierung wolfgang
thierse damals noch als
bundestagsvizepräsident so mächtige
nachwuchspolitiker wie paul signac von
der jungen union sogar die größte
volkspartei die deutschland noch zu
bieten hat die cdu hat im jahr 2008 auf
einem bundesparteitag genau das
beschlossen was wir heute hier fordern
und wir werden sie daran messen meine
damen und herren von der cdu
wie sie sich heute hier verhalten hinter
der forderung steht auch der verein
deutsche sprache der größte sprach
verein in deutschland mit etwa 30.000
mitgliedern und nicht zuletzt indirekt
die von uns hoch geschätzte frau diskus
die herausgearbeitet hat sinngemäß dass
jenseits der deutsche sprache sie keinen
keine kulturellen verbindungen und
findet freistoß das ist doch wenn sie
war sie erkennen dass die deutsche
sprache das einzige element sein so was
uns verbindet er wert in die verfassung
aufgenommen zu hören warum wollen wir
das tun meine damen und herren
die deutsche sprache ist in gefahr sie
ist in gefahr durch überflutung durch
anglizismen sie ist in gefahr durch
einen um sich greifenden englisch waren
an universitäten wo ganze studiengänge
auf englisch angeboten werden sie ist in
gefahr in der wirtschaft sie sind gefahr
in der wirtschaft wo aus vorauseilendem
gehorsam englisch gesprochen werde ich
zitiere da mal walter krämer nur
verlierer sprechen englisch oder
denglisch und ich weiß gar nicht ob ich
da die deutsche bank denken muss aber
sie sehen auch die konzern sprachen
teilweise was damit zu tun wie es
funktioniert nicht funktioniert in der
wirtschaft und schließlich ist die
deutsche sprache in gefahr in der
wissenschaft wo immer mehr publiziert
wird auf englisch sogar in studiengängen
wie germanistik wird auf englisch
studiert meine damen und herren
da müssen wir einhalt gewähren die
deutsche frage ist auch in gefahr durch
eine massive zuwanderung wir haben es
mitbekommen in letzter zeit die deutsche
polizei twittert informiert und belehrt
auf arabisch und türkisch die thüringer
polizei wird auf arabisch behörden
informieren und kommunizieren auf
türkisch und arabisch meine damen und
herren das ist kein beitrag zur
integration dafür der anpassungsdruck
den wollen wir herstellen und dann
können sie auch die zustimmen es ist
eine maßnahme im sinne der integration
unserem antrag zuzustimmen meine damen
und herren ich zitiere norbert lammert
am elften elften wir finden im
grundgesetz inzwischen seitenlange
verfahrensregeln für asylbewerber die
wenn sie das grundgesetz lesen könnten
zwar viel über das regelsystem unseres
landes und seine behörden erfuhren nicht
aber in welcher sprache
hierzulande integration gelingt oder
eben nicht gelingt die landessprache ist
deutsch sagt lammert punkt sagt lammert
ein solcher schlichter satz hätte schon
vor vielen jahren manch hoch
ideologische streit um mich zu sagen
quark sagt lammert vermeiden können
meine damals eher an dem ist nichts
hinzuzufügen aus meiner sicht wir haben
1 1 einfach gesetzliche regelungen im
gerichtsverfassungsgesetz im
verwaltungsverfahrensgesetz aber wir
müssen es grund gesetzlich regeln
damit diese einfach gesetzlichen
regelungen nicht einfach gesetzlich
gegen mann außer kraft gesetzt werden
meine damen und herren
sie müssen auch keine angst haben wenn
der antrag durchgeht wir wollen
niemandem verbieten deutsch oder
ausländische sprachen zu hause zu
benutzen oder in der öffentlichkeit zu
benutzen wir haben einen artikel 22
absatz 2
da ist die bundesflagge schwarz-rot-gold
vorgeschrieben steht im grundgesetz
da ist auch keiner gezwungen sich eine
bundesflagge zwar und ins wohnzimmer zu
stellen und genau so wird es auch hier
gehandhabt eine freiwillige regelung im
bereich des privaten also fliesen und
sorgen müssen sich auch keine sorgen
meine damen und herren machen haben sie
mut courage
machen sie was gutes draus und vermeiden
sie bitte vermeiden sie bitte
[Musik]
vermeiden sie bitte in den
anschließenden reden ohne die vier
deutschen worte hass rassismus hetze und
folglich auszukommen meine damen und
herren ich bin gespannt herum gebrüll
lässt ja schon einiges befürchten muss
ich sagen ich bin ganz ruhig sitzt auch
hier vorne sie müssen nicht so schreiben
dass ich gehen nicht wieder nach hinten
ich bin gespannt auf die rede meinen
namen nach eine sache gemacht hat noch
ein versprechen auch einlösen wie war
benedikt ist mein sohn lieber benedikt
ich grüße dich von diesem rednerpult
vielen dank das war eine klare botschaft
auch auf deutsch formuliert hier der
antrag der afg artikel 22 absatz 3 die
landessprache der bundesrepublik
deutschland ist deutsch
das will die hft hinzufügen gitta
connemann jetzt nicht der
fraktionsvorsitzende der cdu/csu sie hat
mich geprägt
denn sie ist mehr als ein instrument ist
ausdruck unserer kultur deutsches die
sprache der philosophie der dichter der
denker wegen ihrer ausdruckskraft
zeitgeist weltschmerz kindergarten oder
gemütlichkeit das geht in keiner anderen
sprache
ich liebe die deutsche sprache deshalb
ärgere ich mich über anglizismen und
wichtigtuer die ihre reden mit
fremdwörtern spicken die von letter of
intent stadt von absichtserklärungen von
obsolet stadt überflüssig sprechen
ich sage ihnen point of sale heidi range
und cream oder facility manager das geht
auch auf deutsch und alt und jung würde
es verstehen
deshalb setzt sich und die mitglieder
unserer fraktion seit jahren für die
deutsche sprache ein norbert lammer
wurde als sprachwahrer des jahres
ausgezeichnet übrigens auch peter
ramsauer der eine deutsche initiative im
bundesverkehrsministerium auf den weg
brachte
seitdem heißt es nicht mehr travel
management sondern reisestelle die cdu
deutschlands hat sich mehrfach dafür
ausgesprochen die deutsche sprache im
grundgesetz zu verankern meine damen und
herren auch auf der tribüne das fordert
jetzt auch die afd
die frage warum nicht zustimmen
es gibt rechtliche gründe hierzu werden
meine kolleginnen und kollegen etwas
sagen mein augenmerk liegt aber auf der
sprache unserer fraktion geht es nämlich
nicht um deutschtümelei oder um
selbstdarstellung sondern um die sprache
wir wissen erstens sie muss gepflegt
werden 2 sie muss verständlich sein
drittens sie soll verbinden und nicht
trennen genau das unterscheidet uns von
der arzt ihnen geht es um eines nicht
die deutsche sprache beweis gefällig ihr
antrag strotzt nur so von fremdwörtern
ich zitiere deklaratorisch haupt
kommunikationsmedium identifikation und
und und brauchen sie das wirklich oder
wussten sie es nicht besser
dabei gibt es einen redaktionsstab der
gesellschaft für deutsche sprache beim
deutschen bundestag die freundlichen
mitarbeiter hätten ihnen auch gerne
geholfen bei ihrem bau der welt schwere
hilfe sicherlich auch nötig gewesen
das wird übrigens auch in sachen
verständlichkeit
wer bandwurmsätze liebt kommt bei ihnen
voll auf die kosten ich zitiere die
deutsche sprache ist als das primäre
mittel zur verständigung der deutschen
zugleich das medium unserer sprachlichen
kultur der sprachlichen
persönlichkeitsbildung und der
individuellen wie gemeinschaftliche
identifikation verstehen sie eigentlich
ihre absprach konnte mein deutschlehrer
hätte aber ausdruck hinter diesen satz
geschrieben gutes deutsch weit gefehlt
wir waren zitiert was in anderen
sprachen dargestellt wird schauen sie
mal in ihr eigenen internetauftritt da
gibt es ihr grundsatzprogramm in
russischer sprache
[Applaus]
viertens an schlimmsten ist aber ihr
eigentliche antrieb für uns in der union
ist sprache etwas verbindendes sie
nutzen sprache um zu entkommen um
auszugrenzen und zu spalten
was ich weiß ist der vorläufer zu diesem
antrag da steht keines der ach so
schönen worte über die bedeutung unserer
sprache für philosophie für
kulturwissenschaften nein der kollege
brandner zeichnet in diesem vorläufer
vor allem ein zerrbild über migranten
und dustin schlechten deutsch ich
zitiere spiegelbildlich zur
gesellschaftlichen segmentierung und
abkapselung der migranten in ihren
jeweiligen milieus steigt die
berechtigte erwartungshaltung der
deutschen mehrheitsgesellschaft die von
ihnen zu recht erwarten kann sich den
landestypischen regularien anzufassen
kollegin scheunemann
der kollege spangenberg würde gerne eine
zwischenfrage stellen geben sie mir da
nicht recht das ist es gerade notwendig
ist deutsch ins grundgesetz einzunehmen
wenn auch die afg solche fehler macht
ich habe ihre ich habe ihre frage nicht
verstanden herr kollege steinberg würden
sie sie bitte wiederholen meint meine
liebe kollegen kollegen wenn sie einfach
den lärmpegel so halten dass die
rednerin auch die frage verstehen kann
denn nur dann kann sie darauf antworten
herr kollege spannende wiederholen die
frage frau kollegin geben sie mir doch
recht dass wegen die afg auch solche
fehler macht dass das gerade wichtig ist
dass wir deutsches grundgesetz im himmel
ja jetzt macht ihr antrag natürlich sinn
ich verstehe das aber dann würde ich
doch empfehlen bevor die alles ins
grundgesetz schreiben doch erst einmal
deutsch zu lernen
ich durfte ja gerade aus ihrem vorläufer
antrag zitieren in die endfassung hat es
diese stilblüte übrigens nicht geschafft
der antrag ist weich gespült worden um
sich einen bürgerlichen anstrich zu
geben dankenswerterweise hatte herr
kollege brandner den ursprünglichen
antrag aber ins netz gestellt sie hatten
doch wohl ich etwa ein sinneswandel wohl
kaum wenn ich mir ihre sonstige sprache
vor augen führe von volkskörper bis mi
gras ohren auf gut deutsch
sie verschleiern ihre eigentliche
absicht sie sind wölfe im schafspelz und
deshalb lehnen wir ihren tanzpartner
gitta connemann war dass die
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion deutsch
als landessprache fordert die afg arena
in der debatte machen modellsystem er
von der spd ist mitglied im
innenausschuss
sehr geehrter präsident verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen ich habe als
schüler mir damals so ein paar euro dazu
verdient mit nachhilfe in deutsch dass
sich das als abgeordneter mal vor diesem
hause fraktion tun würde die neu hinzu
kommt hätte ich mir auch nicht träumen
lassen die sache aber wer fremde sprache
nicht kennt weiß nichts von seiner
eigenen was hätte goethe von dem dieser
ausspruch stammt wo zu ihrem
gesetzesentwurf gesagt ich bin mir
sicher er hätte sich geschämt
sie sprechen von verdrängung der
deutschen sprache und das deutsch die
primäre verständigung der deutschen sein
gerade deshalb sollten wir das
grundgesetzlich kennt verdammt noch mal
die finger davon lassen veränderungen
daran vornehmen zu wollen
sie verkennen dass das grundgesetz nicht
nur grundrechte für deutsche sondern
auch grundrechte für alle menschen die
in dessen geltungsbereich leben fest
schreibt und vielmehr verkennen sie dass
sie im in und ausland deutsch gesprochen
wird
nicht umsonst ist das goethe-institut
mit 159 einrichtungen
98 ländern gegenwärtig und vermittelt
die deutsche sprache und die deutsche
kultur
aber welches deutsch eigentlich das
deutsch dass wir heute sprechen ist
nicht einmal mehr dass deutsch von vor
20 jahren von den über 50 mundarten mal
ganz zu schweigen
unsere sprache ist eine summe aus dem
grundrechtlich zugestandenen freiheiten
die eigene persönlichkeit frei zu
entfalten
unsere verfassung ist im
gesellschaftlichen wandel gegenüber
aufgeschlossen und genauso ist es mit
der deutschen sprache auch diese in
einen idealen zustand pressen und
bewahren zu wollen käme der
ungerechtfertigten einschränkung von
grundrechten gleichen das anliegen das
anliegen der afg fraktion ist daher viel
weniger redlich als uns der
gesetzesentwurf glauben zu machen
versucht denn er schützt ängste ängste
die jeder grundlage entbehren
ängste ohne die eine afd in deutschland
ihre anhängerschaft verloren
der gesetzesentwurf zeichnet darüber
hinaus ein unwahres ein düsteres bild
es klingt beinahe nach dem eintritt des
verteidigungs falles wenn man ihrer
sachverhaltsdarstellung folgt dass
anglizismen demnächst unsere deutsche
sprache übernehmen werden vielmehr lösen
sie durch diese bösartigen
unterstellungen bösartigen
unterstellungen den demokratischen
verteidigungsfall aus der mehrheit
dieses wohnhauses verteidigen wir die
menschen vor ihnen die mit ihrer eigenen
deutschen sprache die kulturelle
vielfalt die wissenschaft das
miteinander in diesem land fördern als
ausfluss ihres allgemeinen
persönlichkeitsrechts
keiner der anwesenden wird ernsthaft
bestreiten können dass die deutsche
sprache schon jetzt
verfassungsrechtliche bedeutung hat das
grundgesetz der bundesrepublik
deutschland ist schließlich auf deutsch
verfasst auch da kann ich ihnen gerne
noch mal nachhilfe geben wenn sie das
benötigen die geltung des deutschen
grundgesetzes bedeutet zugleich die
geltung der deutschen sprache und
genießt somit verfassungsrang
lesen bildet menschen die im
geltungsbereich unseres grundgesetzes
leben müssen sich daher die deutsche
sprache aneignen denn ohne die deutsche
sprache sind sie vor behörden vor
gericht und in der demokratischen
auseinandersetzung unterlegen
nur wer die verfassung nur für die
sprache der verfassung des landes in dem
er lebt beherrscht nur der findet schutz
und eine heimat oder mit goethe der
deutsche soll alle sprachen lernen damit
ihm zu hause kein fremder unbequem aber
in der fremde
überall zu hause ist kurzum dass das
grundgesetz in deutscher sprache braucht
einen solchen zusatz nicht und am
niederrhein hätte man ihnen
wahrscheinlich gesagt da haben die
schwadroneur ist matthäus
zusammengeprügelt
jetzt verteidigt das wort dem kollegen
stephan thomae fdp fraktion stefan thomé
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
der liberalen im parlament an den
apotheker patienten auf tragen
wie lange wollen sicherlich noch die
geduld des hauses missbrauchen
mit ihren deutschtümelnden anträgen mehr
damen und herren heute also mit einem
vorschlag zur grundgesetzänderung
ich habe mich ja immer schon als
verfassungsgericht entschuldige sich das
fremdwort als erfassungs kur ist bekannt
der gegen jegliche verfassungswidrig an
kämpft auch gegen eine banalisierung des
grundgesetzes gegen vorschriften die
keine weitreichende folgen haben
was ist denn die aufgabe unserer
verfassung die fassung soll den
staatsaufbau ordnen und sie soll die
freiheits und abwehr rechte der bürger
gegen den staat und gegenüber dem staat
definiert
aber sie sollen nicht die
lebensgewohnheiten der menschen regeln
sie sind auch nicht die
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten entwicklung
streben der gesellschaft behindern
blockieren einlegen oder bremsen vor
allem die sprache ist etwas lebendiges
hat das vital ist was ich ständig ändert
was sich weiterentwickelt und die
sprache ist aufnahmefähig sie ist offen
ein offenes system sie haben selbst wir
sollten courage haben ihrem vorschlag
zuzustimmen dann sieht man schon dass
unsere sprache das aufnimmt dass sie
damit umgehen kann ohne dass sie
nachhaltigen schaden nehmen muss das ist
das ist der erste grund weshalb wir
ihrem antrag in der sache nicht
zustimmen werden ich will aber zum
zweiten noch etwas ganz grundsätzliches
sagen wissen sie auch ich habe einen
sinn für sprache für das schöne
klingende das ästhetische unser sprache
aber auch wenn ich diesen aspekt teile
trennt mich eines doch von der ganzen
intonation ihres antrags nämlich
ihr ganz antrag die angst vor dem neuen
atmet und aus angst wird das noch was
kann gewalt entstehen
nicht jede veränderung nicht jede
veränderung ist eine degeneration
sprache ist ein hochkomplexes system
lebendige sprache ist komplex und ihr
ansatz sprachpflege zu betreiben die
reinheit der sprache zu bewahren ist von
ihrem ansatz her dass im grundgesetz zu
regeln höchst und zutiefst unterkomplex
das sieht man schon daran dass unsere
sprache den wert aus dem lateinischen
kennt das sie fremdwörter aus dem
französischen übernimmt das die ganze
musik durchzogen ist von sprach
unterlegung in lateinischer sprache
italienische opern und dergleichen mehr
sprachkultur ist nicht retro weil damen
und herren herr kollege türme der
kollege hamburg würde gerne eine
zwischenfrage stellen
armin paul hampel von der afg
mittlerweile gibt es für die bei jedem
redner eine zwischenfrage sprach immer
im wandel ist und sich immer erneuert
und das das grunde genommen von
gesetzliche regelung ausgeschlossen sein
sollte gab von verfassungsrechtliche
regelung zwar können sie mir sagen warum
wird dann eine rechtschreibreform in
deutschland hatten die deutschen keinen
kein kein gesetz aber recht reihe und
dient natürlich auch dazu dass das wir
dass wir im lesen und leicht bewegen
können es ist schon ein teil der
sprachkultur sich aber nicht im gesetz
war mit dem grundgesetz festgeschrieben
wie wir rechtschreiben es gibt es gibt
staaten
es gibt statt in rechtschreibung gesetz
ist unser nachbarland frankreich kennt
das zb aus reviews zeiten ist es
innovationen her durch die akzentsetzung
eine gesetzliche regelung das kennen wir
in deutschland nicht es gibt kein gesetz
zur rechtschreibung und trotzdem sehen
sie wir kommen damit ganz gut zurecht es
gibt vorschläge über grafisches tool den
mann helmut der gleichen reaktionen die
uns vorschläge unterbreiten wie wir zu
schreiben haben aber wenn sie es anders
tun müssen sich eine haftstrafe
fürchten nicht einmal geldstrafe der
gerichte und daran sieht man daran sieht
man wir kommen ganz gut damit zurecht
sie verändert sich auch auf die
rechtschreibung hat sich verändert es
gibt es reformen dazu es gibt auch
länder die an der rechtschreibung
pflegen die schweiz und andere länder
ohne dass das unser sprache einem
abbruch tut herr kollege stürmer der
kollege spangenberg würde auch noch
gerne jetzt wissen frage stellen sehr
gerne dann läuft die zeit langsam werde
kollege ist ihnen bekannt dass in der
französischen verfassung der satz drin
steht die sprache der republik ist
französisch
das war mir bislang nicht bekannt ich
sehe man kann heute auch auf leeren aber
das heißt nicht dass wir es auch
benötigen bei uns ich habe gerade eben
ausgeführt dass die franzosen eine
angstreaktion haben eine andere kultur
das kommt noch aus touristischen zeiten
das heißt nicht dass wir das auch
benötigen das heißt und daran sehen wir
auch dass in unserem land deutsche
sprache gesprochen wird geschrieben wird
auch ohne dass irgend einer
festschreibung im grundgesetz oder im
gesetz bedarf aber es zeigt eines dass
sie diese diese angst vor veränderung
haben das atmet ihren ganzen antrag das
durchzieht ihren antrag
sie pflegen einen romantischen
verklärten kulturbegriff den wir nicht
benötigen
sie haben angst vor dem neuen angst vor
veränderung haben angst vor der zukunft
und dagegen setzen wir vertrauen in die
zukunft setzen wir optimismus setzen wir
mut zur veränderung das neue und herren
das braucht unser land
jetzt deutsch als landessprache
diskutiert hier der deutsche bundestag
selbstverständlich auf deutsch ich kann
mich auch nicht erinnern dass hier
anders geredet wurde
und nächste rednerin ist in der debatte
simone barrientos von der linken
sehr geehrter präsident werte
kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben heute
eine delegation aus der us national
ich freue mich dass ich nachher einen
der kollegen treffen michelle via veneto
moslems der pummelige mutu unsere
gemeinsame sprache ist spanisch und wenn
ich nach rechts schauen dann sieht man
ziemlich deutlich dass qualität und
quantität nicht viel miteinander zu tun
haben
heute waren wir ein gesetzentwurf der
wie so oft die gesetzentwürfe oder
eigentlich immer keinen symbolcharakter
hat diesmal will die afg dem grundgesetz
ans eingemachte die deutsche sprache sei
in gefahr
dabei gehört deutsch zu den zehn am
meisten gesprochenen sprachen auf der
welt und sie kam deshalb 2006 ins
guinness buch der rekorde
wo also ist bitte die gefahr
die debatte die man daran stoßen will
die ist weder neu noch ist die zeit
gemäß den in allen zeiten gab es jene
die sich an althergebrachtes klammerten
und solche die begeistert die
entwicklung begrüßten und sprache ist
weder ein starkes konstrukt noch ist sie
völlig losgelöst von regeln den
gebrüdern grimm sei dank an dieser
stelle der afg geht es weder um die
förderung der deutschen sprache noch um
den erhalt von kultur ihr geht es um
deutungshoheit
denn sonst würde sie einen antrag
stellen der zb bildung fördert wir
stellen sich drei fragen was sagt die
afd
was meint die afd was will die afd sage
ich ihnen gerne
sie sagen volk sie meinen völkisch und
sie wollen ausgrenzen
ein geschmäckle hat dabei das ist die
afg war die mit russischsprachiger
wahlwerbung in dem wahlkampf zog
so sah das aus und das darf lässt nur
den schluss zu dass es eben nicht um
sprache geht nein es geht um von der afg
definierte völkische zugehörigkeit und
die afg sagt also die deutsche sprache
müsse im grundgesetz verankert werden
aber welche sprache meint sie
literarisches deutsch ich glaube nicht
gender gerecht ist deutsch im
amtsdeutsch kann es hier nicht gehen das
ist ja bereits verankert gesetzlich ihr
geht es um völkisches deutsche sprache
als mittel zur ausgrenzung und was soll
dann bitte konkret folgen die einsetzung
einer reichs pardon einer bundes kultur
kammer die frage ist eben nicht welche
sprache man spricht die sprache frage
ist was man sagt und was man wieder sagt
macht und da ist die afg vorreiter
seit jahren arbeitet sie daran
unsägliches wieder sagt ba zu machen
da wird folglich schwadroniert was das
zeug hält
und an dieser stelle an einer stelle
wird die vorlage sogar ein bisschen vom
krieg die afg will der freiheit der
programmgestaltung des öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunks ans leder
da soll reguliert werden im sinne der
afg versteht sich vielen dank auch das
ist schon ein starkes stück
das ist schon ein starkes stück dass
ausgerechnet diese partei die sprache
vor allem dazu nutzt um haft zu sehen
um den gesellschaftlichen diskurs zu
sabotieren
um auszugrenzen und anzugreifen um
frauen zu beleidigen um homosexuelle
verächtlich zu machen um zugewandt
zugewanderte die verlieren um politische
gegner nieder zu brüllen und anzupöbeln
dass ausgerechnet diese leute sprache
als kulturgut im grundgesetz verankert
haben wollen
unfassbar
wenn da was geht im grundgesetz dann ist
es kultur als staatsziel und zwar kultur
in all ihrer buntheit frau kollegin
achten sie bitte auf ihre redezeit des
abgelaufenen ja ich bin im prinzip
fertig lassen sie sich lassen sie mich
mit heilig heinrich heine schließen
fatal ist mir dass noten packt das um
das herz zu rühren den patriotismus
trägt zur schau mit allen seinen
geschwüren vielen dank
simone barrientos war das von der linken
mit heinrich heine hier gegen den antrag
der raf die deutsch als landessprache
und gesetz einzuführen
nächster redner kommt von den
bündnisgrünen erhard grundl der
präsident sehr geehrte damen und herren
sehr geehrte gäste auf der tribüne muss
man mit den worten des bayerischen
philosophen gerhard polt zu fragen
braucht es braucht das zitat ende
nach paragraf 23 des bundes
verwaltungsverfahrensgesetzes ist
deutsch in parlamenten und gerichten
längst verpflichtend warum fordert die
afg trotz dieser tatsache hier und heute
eine änderung des grundgesetzes
es ist das ewig gleiche spiel
letzte woche noch hat einer dieser
abgeordneten hier im parlament vom dom
volkstod gesprochen heute malen sie uns
zur abwechslung mal den niedergang der
deutschen sprache an ihre klagemauer der
ängstlichkeit dass wir deutsche eine
anerkannte wissenschaftssprache sowie
eine vielfältige deutsche literatur und
medien sprache haben spielt da natürlich
keine rolle
acht der zehn erfolgreichsten künstler
des jahres 2017 in den deutschen charts
waren produktionen in deutscher sprache
produkte in deutscher sprache buben in
den charts und das ganz alles ohne ihre
bevormundung wenn sie von der afg schon
die musikbranche in ihrer begründung
bemühen dann machen sie sich bitte
fakten fest aber es geht der afg nicht
um das was wirklich ist es geht wie
immer nur um eins es geht darum
auszuführen weltuntergangs szenarien zu
entwerfen und zu spalten
es geht der afd darum die eigene
kleinkariertheit unserem land und seiner
bevölkerung überzustülpen was die afg
hier vorlegt ist nicht neu es ist auch
nicht provokant es ist rückwärtsgewandt
und kulturell einfältig es ist eine
wagenburg die die weiterentwicklung
unserer sprache stärker bedroht als es
jede veränderung tun könnte warum sagen
sie aber eigentlich nicht was sie
wirklich wollen
sie wollen in wahrheit eine deutsche
leitkultur ins grundgesetz schreiben
aber ich kann ihnen sagen warum sie das
nicht tun weil sie gar nicht wissen was
diese deutsche kultur ausmacht
herr kollege braucht ja ich weiß bei
ihnen weiß man nie ob sie morgens mit
der schmusedecke oder hinter markierte
aufgewacht sind aber ich würde ihnen
empfehlen einfach mal zuzuhören und zu
relaxen
sie haben keinen positiven begriff von
unserer kultur
was ist denn dieses eigene dass sie
verteidigen wollen was ist ihr positives
bild der deutschen kultur der deutschen
sprache welche deutschen künstler
könnten sie anführen goethe heine thomas
mann funny van dannen rammstein die
ärzte alle diese künstler alle diese
leute die sich mit der deutschen sprache
wirklich auseinandersetzen sie alle
haben sich gegen ihren dumpfen
nationalismus gewandt meine damen und
herren ich bin überzeugt man stärkt
seine muttersprache nicht indem man sie
kleinreden und wehleidig daherkommt wie
es die fdp wenn es ihnen wirklich um
unsere sprache ginge würden sie sich
selbst bewusst einsetzen für guten
sprachunterricht für muttersprachler und
für migrantinnen und migranten
außerdem welches deutsch gesagt für sie
versehen dazu und welches nicht was ist
mit der sprache der hip hopper der
rapper was ist mit dem eigenwilligen
deutsch der trolle die in den sozialen
netzwerken pöbeln und afd positionen
verbreiten bis das ihre landessprache
was ist mit einem minderheiten in
deutschland mit den angestammten
zugewandert und sollen wir denen die
nordfriesische ständig oder sorbisch
wendische und romanisch nackten
demnächst vorschreiben was sie zu reden
haben wie schaut es mit extrem dialekt
wie etwa dem oberfeld sich aus
bei türkisch erübrigt sich die frage
sicherlich für die afd
die afg klappt ganz augenscheinlich
nicht an die kraft und stärke der
deutschen sprache an ihre kraft sich
wandeln zu können
und gerade dadurch einzigartig zu sein
und natürlich wir alle von der
bundeskanzlerin wenn sie da ist bis zu
700 neue parlamentarier in wir chatten
twittern wir leiten rechtsaußen hier
wohl mehr geratet unsere muttersprache
entwickelt sich weiter in alltäglichen
gebrauch durch den erfindungsreichtum in
der jugendsprache im hip hop in der
literatur und ja auch hier im parlament
wäre unsere sprache nicht in der lage
sich zu verändern würde sie ihre
funktion aufgeben als instrument der
kommunikation und der identifikation mit
unserer zeit mit unserem land mit den
menschen die hier zusammenleben
hinter diesen gesetzentwurf steht ein
kulturverständnis der abschottung und
ausgrenzung kulturen und sprachen
verändern sich das macht sie spannend
und reich im austausch der kulturen
entsteht neues dort findet inspiration
stadt nichts davon steht in diesem
gesetzentwurf braucht es laut wollt ich
sage ganz klar nein
vielen dank
jetzt hat nächste rednerin in der
debatte ist die vorsitzende des
bundestagsinnenausschusses andrea
lindholz von der cdu/csu ja sehr
geehrter herr präsident sehr geehrte
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die afd will die deutsche
sprache im grundgesetz verankern und ja
csu und cdu sowie der ehemalige
bundestagspräsident norbert lammer
vertreten la matt vertreten die es auch
bereits seit langem im bundestag gab es
da zu anhörungen stellungnahmen und
petitionen bisher aber keine mehrheit
das ist bedauerlich aber sicher keine
katastrophe die recht zwischen
wissenschaft schreibt heute schon der
deutschen sprache ihren verfassungsrang
zu und das ergibt sich aus unserer
verfassung durch die nennung des
deutschen volkes der deutschen
staatsangehörigkeit und der tatsache
dass unser grundgesetz auch auf deutsch
geschrieben wurde
außerdem ist deutsch im
gerichtsverfassungsgesetz und
verwaltungsverfahrensgesetz unter
anderem verankert es wäre aber auch aus
unserer sicht ein wichtiges signal die
deutsche sprache symbolischem
grundgesetz explizit aufzuführen
und sie sorgt auch für
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt und
identität es gibt viele verfassungen in
europa die ihre sprache dort normiert
haben und deswegen ist die forderung per
se auch nichts schlechtes oder gar
schlimmes deutsch zu sprechen ist
voraussetzung für teilhabe in
deutschland wir fördern deshalb sprach
kitas berufsbezogene sprachliche
förderprogramme
integrationskurse und vieles mehr mit
dem bayrischen integrationsgesetz
verpflichten wir auch zur teilnahme an
sprachkursen denn wir wollen keine
parallelgesellschaften in deutschland
solche maßnahmen sind für den schutz der
deutschen sprache in der praxis
grundsätzlich viel wichtiger als eine
reine symbolpolitik und deswegen habe
ich auch eins eingangs gesagt keine
katastrophe und liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der afg ihr gesetzentwurf
ist wie üblich oberflächlich formuliert
und bei der lösung inhaltslos sie wollen
die deutsche sprache nicht als symbol
verankert wissen sondern als staatsziel
und sie wollen damit quasi sprachpolizei
spielen
sie stehen im krassen widerspruch zu den
meisten rechts kommentaren und die
wissenschaftlichen dienst des
bundestages ich darf zitieren aus ihrem
antrag
unternehmen nutzen die englische sprache
bevorzugt nicht nur für
unternehmensinterne kommunikation
sondern auch für werbemaßnahmen wollen
sie unternehmen also ein ernstes
vorschreiben wie sie ihre werbung
gestalten sollen
oder gar wie sie intern kommunizieren
wollen sie schreiben weiter deutsche
musiker sehen sich gezwungen auf
englisch zu singen wollen sie unseren
radio und fernsehsendern vorschreiben
welche musik sie spielen müssen oder uns
gar welche musik wir hören dürfen
sie wollen in ihrem antrag der
öffentlichen kommunikation staatliche
institutionen über die bereits
verankerte festlegung der deutschen
sprache hinaus weitere vorgaben machen
wollen sie vielleicht mal
wissenschaftlichen kongressen in
deutschland den wissenschaftlern aus
aller welt vorschreiben dass sie nur
deutsch zu sprechen haben und ich muss
ehrlich sagen ich bin stolz auf die
vielen jungen leute in unserem land die
in der lage sind sind sich auf englisch
französisch und spanisch zu verständigen
und auch tatsächlich
in den ganzen aktivieren abzug damit
abzuwarten in der arbeitswelt in der
wissenschaft in der forschung ist die
vielsprachigkeit schlicht gar nicht mehr
weg zu denken und zu guter letzt
besonders enttäuschend ist dass ihr
antrag auch noch mehr als scheinheilig
es samt ihrer ganzen schaufenster
riesige gehalten haben
die kollegin den durchgestanden
nein nein da die kleine zwischenfrage
die kollegin conny mann hat bereits
darauf hingewiesen nicht nur das
programm ihr programm scheinbar ist
scheinbar auf russisch verfasst sie
haben im bundestagswahlkampf in den
landtagswahlen in nordrhein-westfalen
und in berlin
mit flyern und auf wahlplakaten auf
russisch geworden und wer sich hier als
polizei der deutschen sprache als großer
verteidiger auf spielt der muss das dann
erst mal erklären das an
scheinheiligkeit wirklich nicht mehr zu
überbieten was wir hier abliefern
ihnen geht es nicht darum die deutsche
sprache als eine schöne sprache im
grundgesetz zu verankern geht es wie
üblich darum zu spalten und ich möchte
mit goethe schließen ein jeder weil er
spricht glaubt über sprache sprechen zu
können dankeschön
ja der deutsche dichterfürst er ist
jetzt schon das zweite oder dritte mal
zitiert worden
verständlich in so einer debatte johann
saathoff jetzt von der spd
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ja brandner ich muss schon sagen dass
eine beeindruckende liste der
unterstützer die sie hier vorgelegt
haben
aber diese beeindruckende liste ist
nicht der grund für den antrag der
wirkliche grund für ihren antrag des
nationalen abgrenzung und das gehört
hier an den anti tage auf die
tagesordnung gesetzt und ich sage an
dieser stelle mal sie haben kolleginnen
die haben wir eine besonders alpine
affinität zur schweiz
dieses land hat vier ansprachen ist das
vielleicht der heimliche grund warum sie
diesen komischen antrag hergestellt
haben liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
herr brandner wünscht uns mut zur
courage ich übersetze das mal nicht ich
wünsche uns die courage anderen sprachen
mit respekt zu begegnen steigt angst
davor zu haben und sie wollen den wert
der muttersprache in den
gesellschaftlichen fokus setzen meine
muttersprache ist plattdeutsch und dass
sie damals beste was drin in den eigenen
gemeinde habe ich damals wie es oft
schwester tapete ist wenn man mit den
lügen der direkt mit einigen tagen im
orgel platt gesprochen kann ich will
sagen was sie mögen die wurstigkeit
gehen hören aber dessen er hat schlüssel
kommunikation hat ist eine
schlüsselqualifikation machten
gemeinsame sprache damit man sich
gegenseitig ohne holen kann und mit nano
proben kann und so zu steif und den club
lebt in rio wahr die sind sämtliche
heute können bestens platte spucken aber
kein wort hochhuth das sind bestens
integrierte amerikaner und engels
capelight er ohne leben dort in amerika
und wann der winter keine höfe gewissen
sprachen sprachen meine damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sind viel
wert ich habe in der schule englisch
gelernt meine lehrerin würde sagen nicht
gerne ich würde das bestätigen aber ich
bin froh dass ich es kann
sprachen sind im wandel auch die
deutsche sprache ist im wandel natürlich
und niemand ja vielleicht nicht fast
niemand will so sprechen wie man frühe
mittelalter gesprochen hat sprachen
entwickeln sich eben und das ist gut so
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und es
gibt nicht nur deutsch
die vielfalt der sprachen aus den
regionen macht doch den wert
deutschlands unter deutschen sprache
insgesamt auch aus und sich dann so was
wenn man angst helmut dafür wird
irgendein verbuchen noch sieglos in uns
sprach hingeben deutschland profitiert
der fand statt wie tausenden grasen dem
feld 1000 base nimmt weltweit nur wenn
man sie pflegen sie dich überholen und
zu starten kann
auch wenn man die richtige sprache
proben kam und schwimmen
eine sprache täglich sah doch abgesehen
davon dass sie bitte darauf achten dass
wir alle auch verstehen was sie sagen
wollte ich sie fragen ob sie eigentlich
zwischenfrage des kollegen spangenberg
akzeptieren
herr präsident die afg vermutet dass
durch quantität ihrer zwischenfragen
ihrer arbeit mit merck gewertschätzt
wird die qualität lässt aber deutlich zu
leiden
und wir haben das heute erlebt ich lasse
keine zwischenfrage zu wenn man eine
fremdsprache spricht heißt das eben
nicht dass man weniger deutsch sprechen
darf oder muss die aktie sackt sprache
ist kulturgut und ich würde sagen nicht
nur die deutsche sprache ist kulturgut
sondern alle sprachen sind kulturgut
verbände sprachen kennt weiß nicht nur
nichts von seiner wer fremde sprache
nicht kennt weiß nicht nur nichts von
seiner eigenen sprache er weiß auch
nichts von den anderen ländern und deren
menschen und deren beweggründe und er
weiß und wer nichts weiß darüber
der hat angst und wer angst hat der
igelt sich ein und der hat dann
nationalistische tendenzen und wozu das
führt kolleginnen und kollegen das
wissen wir alle miteinander
angst ist also den kunden auch von hoher
politischer an handeln leid kollegen von
afg sind dann so als ob man hörer
wegnehmen höhe wenders der taupunkt
untertägigen dahin lässt eva
deutschlandweit arme
alle sprachen deutschland wurde rieke
und da rücken und wie stolz sehen
wichtig liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ist es verstanden zu werden
den autoren des antrags ist bei den
autoren des antrags ist glaube ich egal
ob ich platt sprechen deutsch englisch
oder kisuaheli hören und verstehen sind
eben zwei verschiedene dinge oder wie
wir noch friesland sagen ich verstehe
die weil man nicht betrübt ihn als
möchte mich abschließend ganz herzlich
entschuldigen beim stenografischen
dienst und ich gelobe besserung
ich danke den bundespräsidenten für das
verständnis zum besten dank bedaueren
live kolleginnen und kollegen ja ein
herrlicher hinweis zum schluss von
johann saathoff der in emden geboren ist
und hier im deutschen parlament mal das
schöne plattdeutsch gesprochen hat es
war dem freiburger wolfgang schäuble
dann doch ein bisschen viel geworden der
ein oder andere hat sich nicht passagen
in der tat nicht verstehen können
insofern ist es in der tat wichtig die
gemeinsame sprache zu sprechen der
nächste redner jetzt kommt von der
cdu/csu ist er ist der letzte in einer
debatte axel müller meine kolleginnen
und kollegen nein das würde ich nicht
tun zumal sich vorweg schicken muss dass
ich mich natürlich freue als baden
württemberger als schwabe zum thema
deutsch als landessprache hier sprechen
zu dürfen
denn wir können ja was haben sie nicht
alles außer hochdeutsch aber nun zur
sache
die afg hat mir antrag dass deutsch als
landessprache im grundgesetz
festgeschrieben wird
gleichlautende gescheiterte anträge hat
die afg in den landesparlamenten von
baden württemberg thüringen und
brandenburg gestellt mit dem gleichen
inhalt aufnahmen die jeweiligen
landesverfassungen wenn wir uns also dem
heutigen antrag zu im grundgesetz ich
versuche die debatte etwas zu
versachlichen im grundgesetz fehlt eine
ausdrückliche nennung einer
gesetzgebungskompetenz für deutsch als
landessprache die sprache kann jedoch
das ist allgemein rechtsansicht der
brandner würden sie auch wissen
neben dem sitz der bundeshauptstadt und
den farben der landesflagge in
ergänzungs artikel 23 grundgesetz
aufgenommen werden
der verweis denn sie vornehmen auf die
österreichische landesverfassung
erübrigt sich denn wie es ein kollege
vorhin schon gesagt hat
das grundgesetz ist in deutsch
geschrieben es wendet sich in
zahlreichen artikeln und an vielen
stellen an die deutschen es ist als eine
selbstverständlichkeit dass das
grundgesetz
deutsch hat dem deutschen einen
verfassungsrat gebilligt hat es stellt
sich die frage ob das was sie wollen
denn notwendig oder zweckmäßig ist wenn
damit lediglich dass es das ergebnis
meiner untersuchungen eine symbolik
verbunden ist darüber lässt sich sicher
trefflich streiten und die cdu kam ja
auch bei zwei bundes parteitagen in 2008
und 2016 zu dem ergebnis dass man diese
symbolik rechnung tragen soll und
deutsch ins grundgesetz aufnehmen möge
ich will nicht verhehlen ich habe dem
zugestimmt habe damals aber fürs
protokoll angebracht dass man aus dem
parteiprogramm angeht ist man doch bitte
dann herausstreichen möge zur
klarstellung ist dass das deutsch als
sprache die landessprache ist aber nicht
erforderlich denn deutsch ist die
sprache staatlichen handelns in paragraf
184 gerichtsverfassungsgesetz und § 23
des verwaltungsverfahrensgesetzes ist es
jeweils festgeschrieben dass die
gerichts und die amtssprache deutsch ist
und ich habe als vorsitzende richter
einer strafkammer darf und auch niemals
bin davon niemals abgewichen und mit
vielleicht vereinzelten abgleiten in den
dialekt gab es da keine abstriche
sie schreiben in ihrem antrag weiter
dass es ihm darauf ankommen die sprache
als medium unserer sprachlichen kultur
zu erhalten
in anbetracht der vielfach um sich
greifenden anglizismen könnte dies
früher als die anträge haben das ja auch
ausdrücklich in ihrer begründung
ausgeführt
aber da muss ich ihnen schon sagen herr
brandt fand sie doch bitte bald in ihrem
eigenen wahlprogramm damit an
dort finden sich worte wie body camp
esel failed states gender studies ja
eines ihrer mitglieder publiziert seit
jahren akademisch nur in englischer
sprache
wie überhaupt das wahlprogramm als
verständigungsmittel dem deutschen
sprache nur unzureichend gerecht wird
eine überprüfung ihres programms mit dem
im vergleich der anderen programme durch
die universität hohenheim im jahre 2017
ergab dass ihr programm von der afd
das am wenigsten verständlich ist in
einer skala von 0 bis 20 erreicht das
gerade mal den wert von 7,3
gott sei dank sind wir an der spitze
gewesen aber es liegt vielleicht auch
daran dass wir keine sätze mit 63
wörtern bilden um zu erklären wie wir
uns den strafvollzug ausländischer
strafgefangener vorstellen
in meiner zweitausbildung als mediator
habe ich irgendwann mal gelernt dass man
immer nach dem wahren interesse eines
standpunktes oder einer haltung fragen
welche ziele verfolgen sie denn wirklich
hingegen ihrer behaupten wollen sie noch
die deutsche sprache als verbindendes
element der in deutschland lebenden
menschen in die verfassung aufnehmen
denn im besonderen teilen ihres antrags
führen sie aus dass dann künftig in der
öffentlichen kommunikation staatlichen
handelns
die institutionen vorgaben gemacht
werden können in gleichlautenden antrag
in baden württemberg haben sie
ausdrücklich vermerkt dass das die
rechtsgrundlage dafür bilden soll
das beispielsweise formulare staatliche
behörden nicht mehr mit mehrsprachig
ausgegeben werden männer achten sie
bitte auf ihre rede zur wand fertig habt
was ich danke ziel ihres antrags ist das
also die menschen die keinen oder nur
unzureichend deutsch sprechen
auszugrenzen sie fernzuhalten von den
einrichtungen oder leistungen dieses
staates das ist aber genau das gegenteil
dessen was artikel 3 absatz 3 des
grundgesetzes fest steigt da heißt es
nämlich ausdrücklich dass niemand wegen
seiner sprache benachteiligt werden darf
daher unterstützen wir ihren antrag weil
er so nicht verfassungskonform ist nicht
vielen dank damit schließt sich die
aussprache in der fraktion allen
überweisung des gesetzentwurfs auf der
drucksache 951 an die in der
tagesordnung aufgeführten ausschüsse
vorgeschlagen